[Music]  Parliament's will debate the latest  brexit guidelines set out by European  leaders any deal struck between the UK  and the EU will need the mep final  approval want to access Spotify Netflix  or Deezer abroad that will soon be  possible Parliament will vote on new  rules allowing subscribers to access  on-demand platforms while travelling in  the EU the UN's newly minted  secretary-general Antonio Guterres is  set to pay his first visit to Parliament  likely on the program are the war in  Syria the refugee crisis and the EU role  on development European lawmakers will  vote on making food donations easier and  clarifying labels like the best before  date which lead to confusion over what  to eat and what to throw out how to help  end the war in Syria the EU foreign  policy chief will be in Parliament to  debate a common European strategy on  resolving the world's worst humanitarian  crisis since World War two